las mujeres son seres irracionales
siempre dadas al desborde emocional por
eso necesitan la custodia de un varón
que es el racional de la familia al
comienzo de sus vidas serán contenidas
por un padre y se aprenden bien lograrán
un buen marido al que tendrán que cuidar
esta frase estaba en la introducción de
un manual para educación de las niñas y
jovencitas sobre el matrimonio que
circulaban en todo el planeta en
diferentes traducciones en la década de
pero la idea en sí tiene cinco milenios
de existencia en todo el planeta en
todas las culturas en todos los momentos
en 1915 en ningún país del mundo las
mujeres podían votar en el 2015 o sea
hoy 60 100 años después
65 países son gobernados por mujeres en
[Aplausos]
en 1910 marie curie ganó el premio nobel
es la única mujer que ganó dos veces el
premio nobel
[Aplausos]
pero la academia de ciencia de francia
dijo que no tenía mérito suficiente para
ser académica y la primera mujer en
francia que entró a la academia de
ciencia fue en 1979 hace 36 años muchos
de los que aquí están ya habían
terminado el primario
la universidad de harvard tiene una
escuela de negocios muy prestigiosa que
recién en 1925 1965 hace ahora 50 años
está festejando eso dejó que una mujer
pudiera hacer la maestría
la universidad de yale admitió mujeres
recién en 1972
la universidad de princeton recién en
1974 y podríamos seguir y seguir
esto era esta idea de que la mujer sólo
sirve para criar hijos y ayudar al
marido que es un ser irracional que es
histérico
era una verdad de hecho hace un siglo la
creía en las mismas mujeres había 1.800
millones de personas en el mundo en ese
momento y casi todas sacando 5000 quizás
creían que esta idea era una verdad de
hecho
porque el mundo cambió tanto en un siglo
es más en los últimos 50 años es cuando
cambio porque estamos viviendo la más
asombrosa transformación en la historia
de la cultura humana estamos cambiando
un paradigma conceptual a otro paradigma
conceptual es una revolución que todas
las revoluciones políticas que hemos
vivido las económicas etcétera son nada
al lado de esto estamos dejando de lado
la idea de que la verdad es verdadera a
la idea de que la verdad es mentira no
existen los hechos sólo existen
interpretaciones
los seres humanos no tenemos una
relación directa con el mundo nos
relacionamos con el mundo a través del
lenguaje
es decir no vemos el mundo vemos nuestra
idea del mundo hace 2.500 años píndaro
ya decía esto en un poema ahora los
neurobiólogos y los psicólogos
cognitivos están estudiando esto podemos
ver el mundo que nuestra mente nos
permite ver no cualquier mundo no el
mundo objetivo
hay una enorme discusión en este momento
acerca de si el mundo que existe allá
afuera alguna vez lo podremos comprender
cuando uno dice que no existen los
hechos que solo existen las
interpretaciones mucha gente cree que la
interpretación es una especie de delirio
personal que la interpretación es algo
subjetivo las interpretaciones son
fuertes argumentaciones sociales son la
base de las ideas no tenemos ninguna
idea humana que no haya surgido de un
marco interpretativo
qué es un marco interpretativo que 10
hoy 24 de septiembre algunos de aquí lo
duda
qué día es para vos
bueno convengamos que es el 24 de
septiembre porque todo lo que estamos
acá estamos de acuerdo con el calendario
gregoriano pero si estuviéramos en el
calendario chino en el hebreo el judío o
cualquiera de los calendarios 500 o más
que existen el 24 de septiembre no
tendría ningún sentido cada cosa que
decimos cada cosa que pensamos cada hito
que ponemos es parte de una construcción
social muy ardua que hemos automatizado
y naturalizado los gatos viven sin
calendario
mi perro ya que adoro y que en este
momento está solito en casa no haciendo
alguna maldad y no conoce la hora no
sabía qué hora voy a volver yo no mira
el reloj si los seres humanos no
tuviéramos estos barcos conceptuales
tendríamos una relación con el mundo que
sería quizás un poco más estímulo
respuesta pero seguramente el mundo en
el que viviríamos no tendría ningún
sentido
toda idea es hija de una época no de una
mente brillante nos han enseñado que
newton estaba sentado abajo de un árbol
pero al caer una manzana fue escribió la
ley de la gravedad que es genio pero no
es así como surgen las ideas las ideas
surgen en la época si darwin hubiera
vivido en el siglo 14 y siendo el mismo
genio que era nunca hubiera podido
desarrollar la teoría de la evolución le
hubieran faltado los viajes que hizo
conocer los animales que vio todo lo que
se había acumulado en el museo británico
los fósiles etcétera además de
y discutir las investigaciones que se
acumularon a lo largo de 500 años por la
difusión de los libros y la imprenta en
el siglo 14 ni siquiera existía la
imprenta no importa cuán genial pueda
ser un hombre si no tiene el contexto no
puede pensar una idea los sabios los
genios son aquellos capaces de
sintetizar una idea pero la época es la
que la genera la teoría de la evolución
sólo pudo haber nacido en el siglo 19 o
no nacido nunca pero si nació nació en
el siglo 19 lo mismo pasa con la teoría
de la relatividad lo mismo pasa con la
mecánica cuántica y lo mismo pasa con lo
que estamos pensando ahora y lo mismo
esto que vemos en los en los movimientos
científicos en la innovación tecnológica
que están cada vez más desarrollados
gracias a este nuevo paradigma de que no
existen los hechos sólo existen
interpretaciones cuando vamos al campo
económico político y social el cambio es
revolucionario como hemos visto durante
miles de años las mujeres fueron las que
se encargaban de la casa y
a los niños y sin embargo en menos de
100 años pasaron a gobernar países la
mitad de las científicas hoy en el mundo
son mujeres la mitad de las profesoras
universitarias son mujeres miren toda la
energía creativa que se perdió la
humanidad por pensar de la manera de que
la mujer no servían para nada más que
para limpiar pañales
cuando se perdió la humanidad cuantos
remedios cuánta inteligencia cuánta
creatividad
o sea las ideas erróneas son monstruosas
hay una idea que la podemos seguir
porque fue creada hace un siglo y medio
y es ejemplar para estudiar este proceso
que es la creación de la homosexualidad
hasta 1860 no había homosexuales en el
mundo ustedes dirán pero como los
griegos y los romanos y los pingüinos y
todas esas cosas y si las relaciones
entre personas del mismo sexo tanto
varones como mujeres o cualquier otro
transgénero que se les ocurre almacenar
hoy este existieron siempre en toda
cultura están en toda época incluso
están documentadas en muchas especies
animales afuera fuera del humano pero
nunca se había pensado que la sexualidad
de una persona anómala como se la
llamaba en ese momento determinaba cómo
era una persona totalmente se creó la
identidad sexual
no fue inocente era el momento de la
generación de la
moral victoriana que fue una de las
grandes formas de control social durante
un siglo y pico más fuerte que existió
porque lo mismo que convertir al sexo en
pecado de la iglesia católica cuando nos
prohíben algo que queremos hacer no te
masturbes
lo harás con culpa o sea lo vas a hacer
pero te va a dar culpa no es cierto
la culpa es un gran control social
[Aplausos]
no desees a la mujer de tu prójimo o al
hombre de tu prójimo
o sea
te va a dar culpa te va a dar culpa y
por ello aunque te da culpa lo haces y
entonces esa es una forma de control
social terrible porque nos domina
doblemente por un lado saben que no
podemos dejar como si nos prohibieran
comer no podemos dejar de comer por eso
somos todos gordos
a través de la prohibición de la
homosexualidad de la censura se cree un
tacho de basura donde todo lo que estaba
mal en la sociedad del punto de vista
sexual se lo puso ahí los homosexuales
durante un siglo fueron terriblemente
perseguidos en todo el mundo no tenían
ni derecho a hablar ni derecho a
defenderse lo mismo que las mujeres
antes no o que los judíos o que los
negros por ciento salidos de la
esclavitud ni hablemos cuando estaban
cuando eran esclavos
también cambio la situación de los
homosexuales también cambio la situación
de los negros también cambio la
situación de los judíos ninguna esa
situación es hoy es ideal pero todos
vivimos mucho mejor más libres y en un
ambiente mucho más tolerante que hace un
siglo que hace 50 años que hace 20 años
hace 10 años atrás los homosexuales en
la argentina no solo no teníamos derecho
al matrimonio sino que no teníamos
derecho a y se queda donar sangre esto
se acaba de levantar ahora en muchas
partes del mundo los homosexuales
todavía son condenados a ser fusilados
pero en muchas partes del mundo hoy son
completamente ilegales esto fue posible
por el cambio de paradigma y porque este
cambio de paradigma permitió la lucha de
gays judíos mujeres negros etcétera
etcétera todos los oprimidos asuman su
identidad se hagan respetar y luego
hagan que los otros comprendan que son
también seres humanos que tienen pleno
derecho pero hay un drama de las luchas
sociales y es que uno tiene que meterse
en la cárcel que me discriminó
para que me respeten como judío tengo
que ser solo judío para que me respeten
como mujer tengo que ser solo mujer como
para que me respeten como negros solo
negro y lo mismo solo gay y los gays las
mujeres los judíos los negros los
blancos todos somos personas completas
complejas contradictorias que a lo mejor
yo no tengo ganas de acostarme con el
tipo que se yo no pero sin embargo tengo
que asumir es son la identidad es una
cárcel quizás la más terrible de la
cárcel de las cárceles
[Aplausos]
hace 50 años y en qué viejo sol yo era
un niño homosexual no sabía lo que era
ser un niño homosexual es más no conocía
la palabra homosexual y tampoco me
decían así mis compañeritos del colegio
me decía gordo [ __ ] te vamos a [ __ ] a
golpes
troll o no me mires
y yo no sabía ni que era hacer troll o
ni gordo [ __ ] ni homosexual ni nada y a
la vez sabía que eso causaba rechazo que
era algo que yo tenía en mí que no sabía
que era volví a mi casa desde el colegio
y veía que mi padre que me adoraba me
miraba y me hace sentir que haber hecho
yo mal para que salga así que era así
tuve que aprender que era ser así tuve
que aprender a ser homosexual
tuve que convertirme en homosexual tuve
que insistir en ser homosexual asumir la
identidad gay tuvo el lado positivo
aprendí a hacerme respetar aprendí los
judíos aquí las mujeres aquí si hay
negros también habrán aprendido lo mismo
que tenía que saber diez veces más que
los otros hacer todo mejor que los otros
no para que me dieran un premio un cargo
o me aplaudieran sino simplemente para
que no me rechazaban
tuve que esforzarme muchísimo y aprendí
muchísimo pero al mismo tiempo me metí
en una prisión terrible que era ser gay
las 24 horas dejé de ser una persona
y yo soy una persona como cualquier otra
persona del mundo soy contradictoria soy
completa soy compleja
me llevo 50 años convencer al resto de
mis conocidos las intervenciones
públicas convencer a los otros que los
homosexuales somos personas y somos
seres humanos y me llevo 50 años
aprender que yo también soy una persona
decir que soy completo complejo
contradictorio que no tengo que ser que
las 24 horas que tengo que escapar de la
identidad hace 20 o 30 años esta idea
que venía teniendo que surge de entender
que no existen los hechos que existen
las
y
y las interpretaciones no existe el
áfrica existen las contradicciones y va
a decir porque realmente es eso somos
contradictorios no existe los hechos
existen las contradicciones y las
contradicciones también son
interpretaciones no existen los hechos
existen las interpretaciones esto quiere
decir que a mí me metieron en una jaula
me metieron en un lugar yo tuve que
asumir quedarme ahí para que defenderme
y ahora quiero salir dije y cuando lo
encarne porque cuando una idea se
encarna es que no moviliza mientras
tenemos solo en la cabeza no nos sirve
la hice cuerpo salí de la prisión y salí
de mi cárcel fue tan maravilloso
vos pensaste en qué cárcel estás
[Aplausos]